okay hey everyone it's Michael BOS from
waterf flows and this is my market
analysis recap for uh Friday May 19th
2017 and what a way to end the week you
know we had those that big down day um
on Wednesday we got some back on
Thursday and we got some back on Friday
and you know even though we're not
ending the week positive the way it
ended was a bit encouraging this is the
daily chart um this was Wednesday the
big down day Thursday we got got some
back Friday very encouraging uh we'll
see how we reopen on Sunday night so
before we jump in uh brief disclaimer
this presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contains substantial
risk and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without shepardizing ones Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results tools I'm going to use in this
presentation are the orderflows trader
which is the volume footprint chart with
my additional orderflow tools to help
your
analysis and
additional tool is the Delta scalper
which I developed to help find turning
points in the market so let's just jump
right in and I'll start first with the
five
years uh F has bit interesting on on
Friday there was a terrific trading
opportunity um early in the morning
Chicago time for just just before 5:00
now you have this low low of the day at
this time uh 11 1818 even you get a
Divergence you get the price rejector
price rejector is something that's
available for my inner circle members
and that's this green line here you have
a ratio you have a Divergence and it's
really all systems go and if you bought
it you know 178 19 traded all the way up
into the uh up here to the 20 22 area
now again you know even though it had a
nice move the only thing I didn't like
about it I say I didn't like about it
but I prefer my trades to happen faster
it went it took about 2 and 1 half hours
for this bar to
finish uh we did put a lot of volume in
here though 50,000 when your normal bars
getting you know at that time this is
pre- Chicago open so to speak pre New
York open rather um and it just it was
just a slow go um from the time you got
the signal to the time you'd get in you
trade 18,000 7,000 here and at this time
the Market's not moving it doesn't go
against you or anything like that but
it's just Market's sort of stuck in a in
a rut but again the only thing is you
know it's the five years and five years
tend to move slow but when the five
years start to move it moves it could it
could move nicely and this was a nice
move here
um you come back down you get down
towards the low again uh one tick above
the
low no signs in there really to be
getting long or anything um you just
have the price rejector down there then
you come up here this is uh 11 you know
you get the Delta scalper given a cell
you hit the same level again I mean you
come off like a tick in the next bar and
then the next bar does rally up to the
high here you do get another ratio and
it doesn't come off now you know this is
part of trade management you know it's
one of these things where the trade's
not working out you know it it doesn't
break in your favor it doesn't go lower
and instead just hangs around most of
the time against you you know it's 12
you know here is is giving you the
signal at 12:07 1221 it's you know it's
still against you 1232 it doesn't get
any lower it just hits the same level
that you hit earlier and you're still
hanging around here around you know
minus one tick minus two ticks and it's
already 1230 here 1:30 you know a move
should have happened already or at least
started to and instead it starts going
against you some more so you know you
got no one to get out of a trade then
you do rally up to these Highs but again
this is Friday afternoon after 2 p.m.
you do have price rejector price
rejector you got ratio ratio as well and
again you really don't muster any move
but you know at this point the cash is
closed so I'm really not interested in
in trading 5 years or bonds for that
matter after the cash is
closed when I talk about cash I'm
talking about the bond cash Market not
the uh not the the equity Futures cash
Market
um this is bonds okay Bonds were also
interesting there was there was a few um
sell signals
early yeah 330 in the morning very tight
range coming into the US session
extremely tight range even though you
have this High here it's
154 sorry 15330 you're low at the time
15322 so you're talking about eight tick
range you do get a sell signal here at
the high at 3:30 in the morning it does
come off does go down into new lows you
know that that's nice but again you know
coming in such a tight range I'm usually
hesitant to take any sort of Trades um
that's just me um unless we're nah I
don't know 330 it's just not honestly is
it worth it can you take it of course
you can take it
um but don't expect big moves you know
when you have a very tight range I guess
is what I'm trying to say then you come
down here you got a Divergence no reason
to buy that one got another Divergence
no reason to buy that you do trade back
up to your high no reason to sell coming
down in here you get the Delta scalper
giving a sell signal you do make a new
low you do have a ratio with price
rejector you don't have a Divergence
which you I'd like to get do you get a
rally yeah you get a little bit but but
you're you know also you're still right
on the back of this uh price rejector as
well so you know if I was short this I'd
be looking to actually cover it possibly
um you do trade back up towards this
High here before going down into the new
lows at this new low this was the
interesting one this one was one that
was very clear you have a ratio you have
a
Divergence you know 35.3 one this next
ratio is 35.3 one that's just
coincidence it's it's not like uh you
know it's a ratio it just involves the
numbers in in
the in the footprint
um the volume is being traded that's all
that's why you got the same ratio it's
no Mass mystical thing but um you do get
a nice move from
15316 all the way up to the 24 area up
here
25 at this area you get the price
rejector which is you know giving you a
bearish sell signal you also got the
Delta scalper does it come off it comes
off a little bit not that much come back
up here same combination but it comes
right down into the single print here
and then we rally up to these new highs
you know Delta scalper is named Delta
scalper because ideally it's it's more
designed for shortterm trading signals
rather than you know long-term even
though you know you do see some nice
long-term trends on the back of it so
you know you might want to if you're
trading that think about trailing your
stop um then up here later again this is
at 3:00 it's a ratio with a Divergence
but again I'm not really interested and
taking that at at 3 p.m. on a
Friday um
next thing I'll talk about really quick
e minis this is a 10 range chart I'll
talk about the four range I just want to
highlight this 10 range chart here
really quick now this is something I
talked about you know if you a way you
can help
determine if you're coming into a trend
day and I talk about this in my inner
circle for the members of the Inner
Circle you know how to define Trend days
early you know cuz if you can get in a
trend day early right you know imagine
right this is your your daily chart
okay and so imagine you know you're
trading you know before you get this big
move to up to 87 and a half or whatever
and you're trading down here in the 70s
you know maybe you're you're at the high
this was uh your high is here at this
time 71 and a half at 5: in the
morning okay and why is that important
well what I do with the chart here it is
um you know if you're trading down here
around 71 72 73 75 even and you you do
get a rally later all the way up to 87
and a half not that saying you'd sell it
up at 87 and a half but you know if
you're trading down in the mid 70s and
things are setting up for a trend day
you know you want to get in as soon as
possible we all love these days these
big candles like this big candles like
this if you could get in you know
somewhere towards the bottom part of
this candle before you get the big long
up candle or the big long down candle so
one of the ways I talk about is watch
the divergences this is a Divergence
with the ratio again this bar takes 2
hours to form in here granted is coming
into Friday morning there's a lot of
stuff going on in the markets the last
couple days so honestly I think people
are a little bit hesitant to really take
any position on until the cash opens but
once the cash opens we we move we
move okay you come up to 79 you got a
failed Divergence
you know 82 you get a failed Divergence
83 a failed Divergence so you get
already getting multiple fail
divergences okay in a short period of
time from 8:54 up to um you know 10:30
so about an hour and a half and then you
just once you take out these highs again
you get a nice move up you know 83 and a
half all the way up to I said you know
88 up here you got a
ratio soor you got Divergence no ratio
the next bar you got the DI you got the
ratio and I of I always say you know be
careful selling divergences because you
know on the way up on a trending Market
you're going to get a lot of failed
divergences you know look for something
in it and I always say get a Divergence
with the ratio as I showed you on the
bonds now you got it here and even
though you don't have the ratio on the
bar with the Divergence look at the next
bar okay it's fine to take it on the
next bar because you might not get it up
there right on you might not get that
price rejection on the high or the price
defense on the high but once you start
moving and you see price rejection you
see price defense either one you it's
usually a decent sign and we make this
move from 832 all the way down you know
below 80s we get down to uh what is that
7879 got a couple price rejector buys
there now even though I was just talking
about the fail divergences now this is a
10 range chart and you'll say Well it
gave me the buy at 83 yeah it did but if
you're looking at where's I'll get you
I'll pull you the four range chart which
is you know a a faster moving
chart it would
be if I could find it it would be a lot
more clearer
early okay so let's take a
look I don't go back that
early oh so we'll just go
back okay so 3:00 this was the time I
started on the other chart so we'll just
take a look that's that one Divergence
you come up here you get a ratio with a
Divergence you sell off you know from 70
A5 all the way down to 67 68 that's on a
four range chart a two-point move is is
you know realistic Target um you know
don't try to get 10 points out of a four
range chart you know that's why you
trade different types of charts you know
you trade 10 range charts when you're
trying to capture bigger moves you trade
four range charts when the Market's
slower and you want to catch smaller
moves you know more often okay so coming
into to the cash open here 8:30 okay so
you had Divergence that failed it's
right ahead of the cash open at 8:30 now
you do have a stack sell in a balance as
well but I know that this is changing
because the cash is open and you're
getting a lot of other stuff coming into
the market at this time so you know even
though you got a lot of sell a lot of
buy and sell signals going off at the
same time it's the cash open and that's
when the big flood of orders start
that's when all the Alo start if you
know I don't care whether you believe me
or not I I know because I sat on Trading
desk cuz I know what time people start
their alos they start in in the snps
they start them on the cash open why
because that's when it's most liquid and
that's when they could move their one
that's when they can move size but more
importantly they're usually starting an
algo at the cash open because they're
doing something in the underlying uh I
say cash Market but the underlying
Equity market so you they're doing their
hedges in the Futures against the cash
position that they're working with in
the stock market that's why they do it
on the cash open that's why they start a
lot of these elos on the cash open so
anyway so I know that and I know you're
going to get a lot of volatility there
and a lot of back and forth so anyway
fail Divergence fail Divergence really
what I'm looking at is and then you get
this run up here
77 fail Divergence here we got three
fail divergences don't have a fail
Divergence up here um you get another
one up here 82 okay you come off a
little bit more fail divergences so you
know if you're not convinced already
that you're going to start to run
then you know you you at some point you
know you just saw a 10-point move and so
hopefully you know you you'd be
realizing that hey you know what we're
we're
moving already I maybe I should get on
board but you know ideally you want to
get in
as as I say lowly as as low as possible
but sometimes you know the market just
doesn't give it to you now I'll just go
through this really quick before I show
you another chart um you know you got a
ratio Divergence fails come right back
up with a stack buying imbalance
um got the ratio Divergence afterwards
you come off a little bit you get your
two points you know fail Divergence
there you know failed Divergence failed
failed di well I say failed here but you
got ratio bonds you got some heavy
volume up here and then you got the
ratio afterwards um you come back up
making new highs all the way up to 88
high of the day right up here you don't
have a
Divergence then you start getting you
got three in a row you don't get the
pullback that you like unfortunately um
you do sell off
um price rejector given a buy down here
Delta scalper given a sell
there and you know a few other sell buy
here and then you just sort of go
sideways into the close but again you
know this is why you should keep
multiple time frames open because you
know sometimes you know if if you're
trading too long a chart I say too long
a duration I guess would be the proper
word
you can miss things and you know this is
the snps this is a three range chart
this time so let's go through this again
8:30 2372 failed Divergence failed
Divergence at 73 at 73 and 3/4 failed
Divergence and this is within 10 minutes
of the cash opening and then you shoot
up so we got three failed divergences so
watch for
signs to buy to be getting long you know
because you know things are picking up
here
cuz on the three- range chart you've
already got three failed divergences in
10 minutes you don't have any failed
Divergence here you got stack buying
imbalance but you know really once you
start getting back you know past three
or more failed divergences in a very
short period of
time you know watch out when you start
breaking out you start breaking out boom
you get very aggressive buying stack
buying and balances you know another two
buying and balances here and a stack
buying and balance on a three range
chart there's only four price levels and
you're getting a stack buying a balance
which you know minimum of three is my
setting so you know that's to me that's
kind of important there um you know get
all way up to 79 you got another failed
Divergence with the with the ratio we do
come off a little bit um you know a
couple points another fail Divergence
know at this point you know if you're
not convinced you're you're still
trading below 2380 on the three range
chart that you know you're getting all
these failed divergences so you know
this Market's already running I don't
know what other sign you need that the
Market's running besides a bunch of
failed divergences and you know buying
imbalances when you take out the highs
so you know this is 2380 you could be
getting
in and you know it just keeps going
higher just keeps going higher here's a
three in a row you don't get the
pullback I mean you do get the pullback
between these two point of controls um
you start shooting
higher you know you just keep going up
and up and
up you know this was a Delta scalper
that didn't work out um again you just
keep going up and up 86 you know here
before you get up to the high of the day
and then here you get the Divergence
nothing but here you get Divergence with
the ratio next bar after you do have a
bullish ratio but here you got a stack
selling a balance I mean so you know
you've got three things two things up
here you got the well three things you
got the Divergence you got the ratio you
got the selling imbalance yes granted
you do have a bullish ratio here but
really you know at this level up here
I'm really looking I'm more interested
for finding a legitimate reason to be
getting short right cuz I know that if I
get short up here I could just hide
behind this High as My Stop and you know
that's going to give me a low risk trade
so I'm getting in at um you know 87 you
know I say 86 and a half 87 my stop just
right up here at you know just behind 88
88 and a qu 8 and and a
half and you know you catch the nice
moves there you're going to catch bigger
moves sometimes going into lows and
necessarily going in or coming off highs
rather than going into new highs you go
into new highs you can run into
resistance on the way up but generally
you know I I find for me it's always
been more profitable to sell off highs
again I'm not trying to pick the high
rather I'm looking for levels to be
getting
short at the high because something in
the orderflow is alerting me that hey
you know what we can possibly be selling
off you got double top up here you got
less volume the second time you got a
ratio you got a Divergence you got price
rejector not price rejector point of
control up near the top then you get a
um stack sell IM balance you got a
single print I mean at that point you
should be already convinced and you know
is there any reason to be getting out of
this trade once it starts coming off no
there's not and it just you know it
happens pretty quick once you get you
know past here 14 uh 203 you know 206
207 209 the bottom just drops right out
and you move down from you know 86 down
into the you know the 80 area and again
you know I mean to get Five Points six
points out of a three- range chart is is
terrific but I'm not saying you know you
can on every time I mean there was some
failed divergences or sorry there's
Divergence with ratios you only got two
points out of but honestly you know on
this move if you're trailing your stop
there's no there's no pullback here
there's no reason to be getting
out okay like you know lots of times you
start selling off then you get a green
bar starts sticking up or you go
sideways it's just straight down it's a
45° move and it's just it's very fast
fast it's very
fast okay so this is the eurocurrency 8
range chart and again it was kind of
choppy uh we did Trend higher most of
the day but still kind of choppy up here
at this High you do have a
Divergence the Delta scoper giv a sell
you don't have a ratio you also got the
transition given a cell you do sell off
a little bit this here is a Delta surge
this green one um you we just sell off
and go sideways take out the high again
Delta surge kicking off
um yeah you just keep popping higher
again that's you know there's there's no
you have the price rejector here but um
you don't have anything else to go
together with it um you get up here you
got a ratio with a
Divergence and you do sell off I mean
you know is a decent sell off about 15
18 ticks um before you rally back up and
sell off some
more Divergence Divergence nothing this
is the Delta scalper given a sell came
right back on the next bar
then again you got some other indicators
here you got this trap Traders indicator
that's this green arrow right there and
then you start rallying you get this big
rally up here you get up here you've got
the
ratio you got the Divergence you go
sideways unfortunately for the next half
uh 40
minutes not really going anywhere you
know you do get you know bullish ratio
here bullish ratio there again I'm not
really looking for reasons to be buying
up here you trade back up within one
tick of the high and then you start
coming off again going into the close so
you know was
there you know was there anything worth
trading me you had a couple ratios with
Divergence you know that give you some
decent trades all right so this is the
uh Japanese Yen let's take a look um
this is early morning looking for any
sort of decent legitimate uh signals
here at 7:30 you do get Delta scoper
giving you a little cell yeah it's again
it's not the biggest move um at this
time of day you it's just before 8:00 I
mean things do pick up after you know
7:20 which is the old floor open but um
again you know so is it a decent move
yeah I don't know it's about a eight
tick move but you do rally you start to
Rally you got all these buy by here
these green arrows which IND me you got
trap Traders down here and guys are
going to start covering you do rally you
get a nice big rally up you again you
got the Trap Trader signal there we do
shoot up a little bit Delta surge giving
you a sell right here at the 90 you know
around the 905 area and you just fall
over you do get Delta scalper given a
buy but it's on a red bar so you
shouldn't shouldn't be taking it okay
you shouldn't be getting long or getting
long on a bar that can't even close
higher it's just it's going to fail so
you know getting a a sell from you know
the 0605 area and you just go lower
shoot lower keep shooting lower shooting
lower point of control right on the
bottom of this bar and you do shoot up
but you mostly go sideways you got point
of control same level the point of
control won't take higher point of
control same level um you know so it's I
I know the Market's going sideways at
this point I really shouldn't think of
holding it much longer I mean how you
can just keep going sideways and once
you go sideways really the inertia from
the reason for taking the trade is died
out
right there's not much more reason to be
taking it and then you come off Delta
scalper giving you a cell there um you
get the push big you know all selling
here all selling imbalances on the way
down you do pop up a little bit and go a
little bit lower you get down you know
from the uh 72 area down into the 60s
mid-60s but you just basically go
sideways what goes sideways you know
every time you get a decent Buy Signal
it doesn't really work out a decent sell
signal doesn't work out it comes right
back on the next bar um we do rally up
here this is already just before
10:00 and then what else we got we got
we got some moves up here you do have
some signs of trap Traders at top of
this bar top of this bar Delta scalper
giv a sell there sorry a buy so you got
a buy and a sell signal right one right
after the other and what do you do you
just you do go
up but it's after this uh after this
signal here but you know what it comes
right back up right and what if you're
if you're looking at these arrows again
these arrows are not to be giving
you uh red light green light systems I
mean it is say okay get short but you
know you still got to manage this trade
you still got to watch what's happening
you know you're starting to sell off but
you see aggressive buying come back in
as you start seeing aggressive buying
back in and you're short that's not a
good sign you should be looking to cut
it price rejector down here and you got
a one lot being traded on that low again
you know what's the importance of one
Lots you know small prints is because
you know just indication that there's no
selling going on anymore you know I mean
if only one lot trades into the bid then
the market turns around goes higher it
doesn't get any clearer to that than
there was lack of Interest selling I
mean that that doesn't take brain uh a
brain surgeon to figure out and then you
start going into the close down in here
you you get this bit of
volatility um you know here just after
2:00 again you get the price
um you get the Trap Trader signal up
there here you get the Delta scalper
given sorry that's the that scalper no
that's the surge rather that you're
coming off but again again it's already
after two you know any sort of moves you
get are going to be kind of muted after
2:00 um even though you know price is
moving it's it's
just you know the FX markets you know
really quiet down after 2: p.m. in the
cash
market after 2: p.m. on Friday you know
everyone you know Europe's gone home
Asia's asleep and Traders in New York
are looking to
uh go enjoy the
weekend
so Excuse excuse
me sorry I keep coughing still just
getting almost over this this nasty cold
um every time I think I'm over it it
sort of comes back and rears its head on
me okay so is there anything else I
haven't looked at beans I mean I looked
at beans earlier uh well I'm recording
this on Saturday night um so I'm sort of
going off some of the trying to remember
the stuff so okay so beans you know 830
is the whoops this is the wrong day here
it is I was going to say that looked
familiar you know with beans 8:30 is the
reopen am I looking at the right
contract July yeah so 8:30 you do start
coming off after 8:30 open up around
your high kind of thin volume um you
know 835 you get the ratio you know here
you got Point control the bot with a
ratio here 835 you do get the Delta
scalper given a buy and here you got
Delta scalper given a sell that one
didn't really work out sort of came back
on you then you hit the high you got a
ratio with the Divergence comes right
back with the bullish ratio but we test
the high again we got another Divergence
starting to see some imbalances coming
in then you get the stack selling
imbalance but doesn't make doesn't make
the move and it comes right back with a
ratio now again I often talk about
selling imbalances stacked imbalances
when you have a you know whether you
have a bullish stacked in balance or a
bearish stacked in Balance watch the
next bar cuz it's going to be very
telling on what's going to happen with
this trade and if you got a stacked
inbalance and it comes stacked selling
IM balance and it comes back with a
bullish ratio it's probably not going to
work out you know it's got a very high
percentage of failing you know you want
a red candle you want a you don't want a
green candle after you get the signal to
get short and you can see it doesn't
work out and it just rallies right up
makes new
highs
um you here you got point of control at
the bottom yeah okay but again I'm not
too convinced at that point that this
move is is necessarily over and then you
get down in here you know it's already
you know this market closes you know
around uh you know 115 so you know I'm
not looking to take any trades down in
here um see if I can find the crude um
crude should be in July
already if you haven't changed your
charts um just go back
here so you know we were we rallying in
the morning you you got the Delta surge
you know this is 8:30
838 you got Delta surge given the buy
you do rally up from you know the 40 45
area all the way up into the you know
into the 70s do start making some new
highs here you got Divergence with the
ratio and if you know you looking to get
short you know you're staring at this
stack this stack buying imbalance which
isn't good but it comes right back you
don't get past this High you don't get
stopped out which is encouraging and
again you get another Divergence and you
get a ratio in the next bar so you know
if you're already short there's no
reason necessarily to be cutting it at
this point you don't hit your stop price
and you just but unfortunately you just
go
sideways okay so you know you you get
your short and then you start lining up
point of controls 1 2 3 4 at the same
level you know after the third one here
again I'm not looking at this third one
I'm looking at this one this one this
one you should be considering you know
cutting your trade already because it's
just not working out at this point now
here you
get um you know Delta scoper giving a
buy going into a high okay you know take
it for what it's worth I'm not a big fan
of buying into highs um Delta Serge giv
a buy but it's a red bar so you know you
shouldn't be really too interested in
taking it you come off a little bit go
sideways and then you start making new
highs going into the
close Okay so the last chart I'll talk
about is the Aussie dollar good day mate
the
um Aussie dollar you know it's an
interesting contract cuz you you get a
lot of activity in the Aussie dollar um
in the evening session evening I say
evening session I mean Chicago time okay
I mean uh you know from the
reopen
until from then on U because basically
you know those that's you know the clock
in Australia versus the time change in
the US is is almost opposite but you
know so that said You know here you got
the price Delta scalper given a nice a
buy here you get a nice run up here um
um you know it's just straight all the
way up from you know what was that where
were we trading there you know
7415 all the way up to 7465 now you're
up into the European session you have a
Divergence don't have anything there but
here you got the Del uh Delta scoper
given a cell okay and it's given to in
the bar right ahead of the price
rejector you know people always say you
know price uh sorry Delta Surge and this
is the Delta surge this is the uh Delta
scalper people always ask you know
what's the difference between Delta
scalper and and Delta surge is you're
not going to get the same signals at the
same time Delta surge was a little
slower than the Delta scalper and you
can see you know if you had the Delta
surge you're catching an extra bar of
profit in here you know if you're
trading the Delta surge it comes off
bces up a little bit here you do have a
bullish ratio you still got negative
Delta though but here you know you're
getting in that much earlier
74 you know 52 rather than
7440 you know
46 you know and you know what's that
worth for you you know an extra eight
ticks six ticks here eight ticks there
you it can make the difference on you
know if you're getting in you know an
extra six eight ticks on each trade you
know at the end of the year I mean that
stuff adds up man you know eight ticks
there's people just happy to make you
know eight ticks on a trade and this
giving you an extra 8 tick profit
potential you know then you you sell you
sell if you get down here to 7430 you
you start rallying you start seeing
price rejection price rejection um now
here you have the positive Delta here
you still have negative Delta with this
ratio of 59.33973
from you know 7450 down into the
7430 so that's 20 ticks right there and
again you know if if you're just in
trading
Aussie you can easily trade it during
the um Asian session it's one of the few
contracts I think you can can trade
during the as look at the volume it's
decent you know you're talking you know
3,000 3,000 um it's just as good as you
know if not better sometimes than what
you're seeing during the the US trading
day okay so thanks thanks for watching
this uh to learn more about the trading
software used in this presentation and
how you can profit from orderflow
Trading visit my website orderflows